welcome back you guys trading off peace
tag team in the peas i like that that's
a good move
did you wash your hands you do oh okay
man we don't do that
we only wash our hands if someone else
is in the bathroom
yo and we might not even do that we
might just turn on the water and look
back like is he looking or
is he watching me fake wash my hands
sometimes you even want to tell the dude
like yo you don't gotta wash them i'm
not judging you bro just go
be great don't be great i know you
didn't pee on your hand
man we do not wash our hands if i wipe
and nothing comes on the toilet paper
i'm not washing my hands either i'm not
i'm not gonna do it for what reason for
what reason my
my [ __ ] is magical if my [ __ ] told me i
don't need a wash
okay
you have to because you're all invested
in you you know
what's that i don't have to i could just
whack and then it's done
i touch my dick but my dick is clean how
often does a guy wash his dick before
you suck it
[ __ ] you make him wet wipe his dick
before you suck it
no you just whip that thing out you suck
it
like i don't get women are so weird like
you're cleanliness [ __ ] right it's like
like i use a [ __ ] wet wipe for your
hands are you
what is that lotion called not the
lotion it's clear
purell right it's it's you purell at
everything but then when we finger you
never purell
right my hands still smell like
hamburgers and you don't even care
[Applause]
i'm smelling my hands as hamburgers bro
i'm just saying you require more cleanup
because you don't have a stream
you just have like a release your [ __ ]
is
have you seen women pee that [ __ ] is a
mess
you pee in one stream don't lie to me
don't [ __ ] lie to me try to pee one
stream that's just coming down both of
your legs
yes that's why you gotta squat way back
like that
you ever see a girl piss in the [ __ ]
street never once you've seen a girl
just piss like that in the street
right if you had any control of the
stream you just lean over you pee like
that
but every time they pee they're like
behind a car
in this like weird squatted motion
right just screaming at their foot block
me
block me block me
right and you're just [ __ ] peeing
into your boot that's what you're doing
you're pissing
right into your [ __ ] boot no toilet
paper nothing
there's a boot full of piss that's why
you wear open-toed shoes so it just
slides right through
you know why those bars are so popular
now it's because men don't know how to
deal with
women in reality so sometimes we gotta
take the fantasy road
the reality of the situation is very
grim
women have made a lot of progress in a
short period of time man it changed
everything
can't deal in relationships anymore i
broke up with my girl i'm out of shawl
shank i'm free
i don't want to go back
i couldn't even argue with her you
should be able to argue if you have an
issue in a relationship
you should be able to argue that issue
out right let's see ladies
you got to stick to the [ __ ] issue
you guys take arguments everywhere just
to win them
that's why nothing ever gets done you'll
be arguing about the dishes baby
baby could you wash your dish at least
before you put in the sink
premature ejaculator
you know why you got to bring that up
i don't even believe in that i don't
if i come man it was right on time
that's what i said
and as far as i'm concerned i can't come
fast enough
i'm sick of being vilified all the time
david how could you how could you come
i was [ __ ] oh what are you trying to
do huh
come well i beat you
you got to work on your time baby i'm
down to a minute 20.
you're mad at me because i have
different goals and sex
i'm a speed [ __ ] just trying to hit my
best time
it's like the olympics and now for the
dismount
it wasn't all bad it's never all bad you
won't stay if it's all bad
well that's not true but i i wouldn't
yeah we had fun we used to watch porn
together that's how cool she was
oh you know it seems nasty but it was
fun
we learned about each other she learned
about me
one time was watching porn i never
forget this time the first
the first scene in this movie was
hardcore
two guys one girl going at it i fast
forwarded right through that
i think it was too much for my senses
the scene after that was these two girls
and this guy
you know i stopped for a minute
i had to see what this was all about and
she noticed
she said what is that now why does that
disgust you
two men and one woman the men aren't
touching each other but the women are
the two women of those men touch each
other the two men don't touch you why is
that nasty to men
and i'll tell you why ladies you can
call me crazy
but i think every every straight man
has a rule
that would be the one penis per fantasy
rule
my dick is the star of my fantasy
nobody else as big as guest star earning
my [ __ ]
this is a dave chappelle joint
yeah look at the whole picture man and
you get two girls and a guy in a room
together that
boy that's something else that's [ __ ]
holding
and hugging friendship and helping
teamwork at its very very best
my friends
you get two guys and a girl in a room
it's the wrong kind of teamwork
brutal if you ask me i'll pull her hair
i'll smack her ass
a poor woman looked like a chicken on a
rotisserie and said help me
[Applause]
if you want to understand men ladies i'm
look i'm here for you
i'm just telling you what we are what we
are you know not who we are what we are
just like what we are
that that makes us struggle and really
men are perfect creatures except for
you know one
like if most women would want to be a
man
if you didn't have to give up that power
that you have which is our weakness
that's our weakness it's very difficult
i'm telling you man
like i don't want to want to be with
other women ever
like i want to just walk down the street
and go i never need to look at another
woman again
because i'm with the last woman i'm ever
going to be and i'm like
but it ain't real it's just
like no guy wants to cheat and hurt his
woman man that hurts
first of all think about what cheating
is for a second ladies
cheating is a man he sneaks out of his
own house
to go like find some happiness behind
your back
so your feelings aren't hurt
cheating is for you it's not
it's not for me
we don't want to hurt you if you give a
lie detective
a man and a woman and ask them the same
questions man
we would pass them both up to a point
where it's like hey
ask a woman you love your man you love
your family you love your home you love
what you built
yep all right you see brad pitt or
denzel washington or whatever standing
there would you risk everything you
built with your man
just to sleep with him and women look
they go nah i wouldn't and they
don't pass the test they'd be like you
know
if they look good but i wouldn't ask
guys the same thing
you know boom love your woman the kids
the ho yeah
i you you see that girl passed out
behind the dumpster
[Applause]
would you risk everything for a passed
out woman behind a dumpster
i don't want to but look at her with
garbage on she looks so cute with
garbage on it
you ever discussed threesomes gorgeous
you never had a threesome discussion
with your man after 10 years like just
even talk to him about it
just to talk like because it'll make him
one just a nice threesome talk
make you feel like oh man just cool that
she lets me get
a little bit of that evil out right
and by the way ladies a threesome is two
girls and a guy
[Applause]
the girls be thinking what about two
guys and a girl is a train
that is me
and him i don't even know him
and he better not look me in the face
like
[ __ ] just get your dick sucked why are
you staring at me
let me [ __ ] my half of the torso
catch this [ __ ] blinking at me while
i'm trying to [ __ ] my half of the body
damn damn man
i think you don't have train etiquette